[موسيقى]
عندما بلغ السادسه من عمره انتظره ابوه
حتى يعود من الكنيسه في قريتهم باسبانيا
واطلعه على السير نحن ابناء المسلمين
العرب الذين وصلوا الى اسبانيا فحكموها ل
ثمانمائه عام دون ان يكره احدا على ترك
دينه ولغته وجعلوها دوره عصرها الى ان خدع
متطرفون اسبان اخر ملوك المسلمين تسلمهم
مفاتيح غرناطه ولما تمكنوا خانوا العهود
واكره المسلمين على تغيير دينهم ولغتهم
وعلى تسليم اولادهم للكنائس ومن يرفض يحرق
حيا او يطلب امام الناس هكذا بدات رحله
الغلام السريه مع القران واللغه العربيه
تلميذا مساء يا عند والده الى ان عاد ذات
يوم من المدرسه فلم يجدوا لديه لقد اعدم
بمخالب وحوش محاكم التفتيش
فر الفتى مع عامه الى بلاد المغرب وعاش
فيها على وصيه والده بحفظ القران ثم كبر
وصار يعلم الناس بل صار العلامه محمد ابن
عبد الرفيع الاندلسي الى العناوين
نتنياهو بليله عرسه في وارسو
السياسي لاوروبا راقبوا المساجد
ضاحي خلفان ام خان اما خوان
طلبات زواج سعوديه اسرائيليه
فور وبوتفليقه تجوب الولايات
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في عيد الحب الخليج ومعه اليمن الى
سده نتنياهو لتقويه ظهره في صفقه عمره اما
مقومه الشاكين باهليته عشيه انتخابات
اسرائيل وزير خارجيه اليمن كان الوجبه
الرئيسيه ولما توقف ميكروفون بنيمين عن
العمل سحب مجاوره اليمني ميكروفون وقدمه
للعريس فما عاد معلوما مكروفون مين بايدنا
العرس تم في وارسو في مؤتمر معزل مكرر
للسلام المفقود في الشرق الاوسط بحضور
الدول الخليجيه الست و 6 ستات اسرائيل
فيما امتلات المقاعد بالعشيقات السابقات
وشهود الزور وقد تولى الزفه نائب الرئيس
الامريكي من هذه المشهديه لاحظت قناه
العربيه السعوديه من دبي ان الاعلام
القطري تعاطي بخجل مع المشاركه القطريه
على الاقل الساحه الى شان مؤتمر وارسو
الدولي حيث شاركت قطر في المؤتمر ممثله
بوزير خارجيتها محمد بن عبد الرحمان
الثاني الاعلام القطري تناول مشاركه وزير
الخارجيه بخجل صحيفه الشرق القطريه قالت
غير ذلك وكتبت تحت الاضواء وامام
الكاميرات شاركت قطر وخرجت من المؤتمر
متمسكه مدافعه عن الحق الفلسطيني والعربي
امام الكاميرات وخلفها وعلى طريقه
الخفافيش شاركت دول الحصار وتسربت الفضائح
لكن هذا الكلام لا ينفي ان قطر حضاره
العرس الحراره مايك بان نائب الرئيس
الامريكي يمدح موقف دول الحصار
اختار تعبيرا كنسيا مسيحيا لوصف اللقاء
نتنياهو بوزراء الامارات والبحرين
والسعوديه قال يكسرون الخبز معا في
استعاده لا هديه واضحه حيث تقول الروايه
المسيحيه ان يسوع كسر الخبز وتقاسمه مع
تلاميذه في العشاء السريه الاخير الذي سبق
اعتقاله ومحاكمته
وصلبه بحسب العقيده المسيحيه على يد
اليهود بعد ان سلمه لهم تلميذه العراق
يهود الاسخريوطي وسبب لهم اخباره مكتب
نتنياهو تسرب اخبار عادل عبد الله خالد
بفيديوهات سحبت لاحقا تضبط بالصوت والصوره
مداخلات اصحاب المعالي التي تعطي اسرائيل
ما لم يحلم به بن غوريون ولا حتى ابو
غوريون بل ان الامر لم يعد يبدو فقط نوعا
من تقاطع المصالح وانما يشكل تحالفا بين
الجانبين بدليل ما تضمنه هذا التسجيل
المصور الذي سربه مكتب رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
لنقاش غير معلن بين وزراء خارجيه كل من
السعوديه والامارات والبحرين على هامش
اجتماع ورسوم بدا وكانه ينطوي على التقارب
الاكثر في الاراء والمواقف خصوصا حيال
العدو المشترك
ايران كيف يصف الخبير العسكري الاسرائيلي
ايا العليمي جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي
يتفهم حقه وزير خارجيه السعاده جيش يفرض
خلاله اكثر من خمسين عاما الاحتلال
الغاشم العنيف على شعب لا يريده ويقوم
بسلم الاراضي يسمى الحقوق المذيعه
الاسرائيليه عشرات كوتلير تعطي وصفا لجنود
الاحتلال
نعجز جميعا عن اطلاقه انهم حيوانات بشريه
يسلم تمه
نستخف ما كنتم خير تدعم بوش كيف يعلق
وزراء التطبيع المجاني على اقفال الاحتلال
ابواب في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وعلى مشهد طرد عائله فلسطينيه من منزلها
في القدس سته عقود ونصف مدعمه بالمستندات
والوثائق لم تكن كافيه للمحكمه الاحتلاليه
التي تنصلت من احقيه عائلتي ابو عصب
للمنزل لارضاء المستوطنين عائله
كبير اقصى
عليه
اذا كان الكلام من فضه فبعض السكوت من
الشيطان
الذي يعد من
قضاه اسرائيليه تقول انك مرات الصحافه كما
نفى وزير الخارجيه العماني في مراب
السيارات اثناء عبوره للقاء مع نتنياهو
كان سريه
سليمان يوسف بن علوي
المال ون ان تكون تينانت والوزير
ثلاثاش من اسرائيل لبناء اجيال مش ايام
والفشل افرتون
رئيس مجلس الامه الكويتي مرزوق الغانم لم
يكن يتمنى رؤيه ممثل دولته مع نتنياهو في
صوره لكن للاسف ظهرت قياداتنا مع صوره
بالنسبه لسؤالك معنا اه مؤتمر اه وارسو
وجود صوره جماعيه في اه وزير
الخارجيه مع الرئيس ويظهر فيها رئيس وزراء
الكيان الغاصب ان المستوى الشخصي انا لا
اتمنى ان تكون هناك صوره تجمع اي مسؤول
عربي او مسلم في العالم رئيس وزراء هذا
الكيان الخاصه لماذا يقدم الحكام العرب
لاسرائيل في السلم ما لم تستطع تحقيقه في
الحرب والاحتلال فخامه الرئيس تمام اما
الخليجيين
قال وتجري الاسبوع المقبل على واصر على
بولندا
وهم صاغرين الحكام العام الحكم الخليجيين
بيهمهم
ما يهمنا من كلام القاها انه رساله ل
حلفاء اسرائيل الجدد حل بكم لا يمنح
حكومات اسرائيل حق حمايه هالكم المقدسه في
اعلامها هذا الان تمارسونه علينا فقط كعرب
اما اعلامه اسرائيل فمن الواضح انه يستعد
لنشر الغسيل ولا تظن بان اسرائيل ستقاطع
كرمال عيونكم يحذركم قيادي فتح احمد غنيم
اللي بيجوا تحالفه تحالف الخائفين مع
الاسرائيليين اكبر خطا استراتيجي انه مش
فاهمين للاسرائيليين ال المنزله التي ت
اليهوديه اليهودي لا يمكن ان يقاتل عن احد
لا بل ان احد اما بموت يهودي واحد علشان
العربي في النهايه هل يتخطى مؤتمر وارسو
ما وصفه به رئيس الوزراء القطري السابق
حمد بن جاسم ال ثاني لتبرير الزواج وكرر
في تغريده بانه ليس ضد التطبيع مع اسرائيل
عندما تكون العلاقه متكافئه وليست على
حساب الحقوق الفلسطينيه
لكن الحضور كانوا اما شهود واما مدعوون
فهناك خطوبه تمت في السابق وهناك عرس تم
في وارسو
[موسيقى]
نعم
في الشان المصري كان يفترض ان يبقى موضوع
التعديلات الدستوريه لتاييد تاكيد حكم
السياسي العنوان الاول لكن مع الارهاب
والضباب واخبار الاعدامات تراجع في
الاعلام الجدل حول الدستور تنفيذ احكام
الاعدام بحق تسعه متهمين مدانين بقضيه
اغتيال النائب العام هشام بركات لاقى
استهجانا حقوقيا دوليا
واعاد الى الذاكره مخاطبه احدهم للقاضي في
جلسه سابقه حيث قال له انا خصيمك يوم
القيامه ان اولى معايا مطلوبين والله فقال
له القاضي بس انت اعترفت محمود فكيف رد
محمود
[موسيقى]
اه
ام
وقبيل التفجيرات والاعدامات كان الرئيس
عبد الفتاح السيسي في مؤتمر ميونيخ للامن
يرشد الاوروبيين الى مراقبه ائمه المساجد
والوعظيه
مع ال اه
يعني شركاء اوروبيين او اي دوله ومنهم من
فضلكم انتبهوا جيدا لما يعني يعني يتم نشر
في دور العباده السياسي ولكثره ظهوره
الاعلامي بدا يستخدم لغه المذيعين يصف
المواطنين بالمشاهدين ويعلن بان المصريين
رفضوا الحكم الديني المشاهدين السمو من ي
من اكثر من اربع سنوات تقريبا
انا تكلمت عن اهميه اه تصويب اصلاح الخطاب
التي اي خرق ثلاثين مليون ونصف ي يرفضوا
الحكم
السياسي الذي اكد علمانيه الدوله اعلن ان
الدوله تبنى دور العباده كان في مصر على
سبيل المثال اه يعني ما فيش ما فيش بناء
الكنائس في الحكومه تقوم به الوقت في مصر
في الكويت المدن الجديد اللي احنا بنعمل
ها احد مفردات
دور العباده المسجد والكنيسه
استغرب الاوروبيون الحاضرون من خلطه حكم
علماني يبنى من عائدات الدوله المساجد
والكنائس
فالدول الاوروبيه حكمها علماني ولا تبنى
لمواطنيها لا دور عباده ولا دور الحاد هذا
كاهل الكنيسه المرقصيه يتدخل في السياسه
لصالح السياسي فما هو مجال علمانيتكم نعم
يتعدد الدستور ومش ياخذ فتره ولا 2 ولا 3
الراء الخاص لا الى نهايه الامر
عاموس يدلين الرئيس السابق للاستخبارات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه نشر صوره له مع
صديقه السياسي وعلق عليها في مؤتمر ميونيخ
للامن مع الرئيس المصري تبادلنا ذكريات
الفتره التي كنا فيها زملاء في
الاستخبارات العسكريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا
ام
[موسيقى]
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
قام بجوله مهمه في شبه القاره الهنديه
وكانت كلماته مؤثره عندما رد على تمنى
رئيس وزراء باكستان برعايه الجاليه
الباكستانيه واطلاق السجناء منها فقال له
مدير اعتبر ان نفر سفير باكستان بالرياض
الوزير عادل الجبير ينشروا بعيد الشر عن
قلبك بس ما تقول ان ما بيحكوا مع بعض
[موسيقى]
عازل من المحل المنيف الحربي الولايات
المتحده لا تستطيع فرض املاءات التسلح على
السعوديه الولايات المتحده مثل الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق لا يستطيع املاء رغباته
على الدول ال المعادله هي معادله مصالح
واه
تفاهمات يعني اه بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه تتخذ قرارها بالتسلح من عده دول
اه في العالم ولا ترجع لاحد في هذا الشان
[موسيقى]
طبعا
الاماراتي ضاحي خلفان او الهندي دخان صار
الاسباني داخل خوان يحمل لواء محاكم
التفتيش الا فرنجيه التي لم تترك للتسامح
ذره من انسانيه
خلفان خوان غضب ما لم يخطر على بال ابو
المتملق الصحفي طوني فقال احتل المسلمون
الاندلس ثمانيه قرون
وعادت الاندلس لاهلها
لكل قوه زوال مهمه الزمن
رئيس وزراء المجر دكتور
الذي يوصف بانه رئيس وزراء اوروبي بنفس
سلبي يتطلع الى تنظيم محاكم ترحيل
للمسلمين تقديم افتحوا اسبانيا ولا يريدهم
ان يفتحوا غدا اوروبا بقنبلتها التناسليه
ايرانيون
حذرت الامم المتحده من ان اسراب الجراد
التي انتشرت في السودان واريتريا متجهه
الى السعوديه ومصر في غضون ثلاثه اشهر فهل
تستعين الرياض والقاهره للشيخ مشاري
العفاسي
الجراد الذي ياكل الاخضر واليابس اتى من
ياكله
رئيسه حزب الاسرائيلي الناس عزاء تبحث عن
حاكم عربي
يكون طويلا
ليتزوجها ويمولها وبين بشار الاسد ومحمد
بن سلمان اختارت الثاني
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
على المستوى وسلام الشرق الاوسط
تدخل بالسياسه الاسرائيليه
تدعم حزب نعم نعم نعم
بيكون كثير
شكرا
والله يزال مالك الا الامير تركي الفيصل
رئيس الاستخبارات السعوديه السابق يلعب في
هذه الايام دور الخطابه عابرا القوميات
والطوائف
سنوات
ان تلغى
اهتم موقع ايران نيوز الاماراتي بنقل صوره
ما قال انها متاجر سعوديه تواكب عيد
العشاق سانتا ليس في السعوديه فقط هنا في
الدوحه حب ناقص على الناسف بثياب النوم في
واجهه احد المحلات التجاريه
وتمت ازاله المشهد بعد وصول الخبر الى
اداره المول
[موسيقى]
فيما كان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يكتشف الشاي مع راعي النظام السوري
الرئيسين الايراني حسن روحاني والروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بحضور الرئيس بيلاروسيا في
مدينه سوتشي الروسيه التي احتضنت القمه
الثلاثيه الرابعه حول سوريا بين الرؤساء
وبين ماكان اردوغان يعلن انه لا يستبعد
القيام بعمليه مشتركه بين تركيا و روسيا
وايران ضد الجماعات المتطرفه في سوريا كان
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد يصف اردوغان
بالاخوان جي والاجير الصغير عند الامريكي
وبغض النظر عن الاستعراضات الاصلاحيه
للاخوه اردوغان الذي يحاول ان يظهر بمظهر
صانع الاحداث في الحقيقه هو عباره عن اجير
صغير عند الامريكي فوجئ المتزلجون في
سوتشي بمهاره الرئيسين الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وال بلا الروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو و
لياقتهما البدنيه اثناء تزلج هما على
منحدرات الجبال في موضوع غير متصل اكد عبد
المالك سلال مدير الحمله الانتخابيه
للرئيس الجزائري عبد العزيز بوتفليقه ان
بوتفليقه ليس في حاجه الى الكرسي هو يقصد
كرسي الرئاسه والمجاهد
في حاجه ل اه
بالكرسي
حياه
وضعت صوره عملا قال الرئيس بوتفليقه على
وجهه احدى الساحات الكبيره ل اعطاء اشاره
الانطلاق بتصدير اول شيء ناتي اسمنت الى
النيجر وقبل شهرين من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
شهدت بعض مدن الجزائر مسيرات رافضه لمجرد
ترشح الرئيس لولايه خامسه فيما وزير العمل
يدعو الى الاحتفال بمجرد فكره ترشح الرئيس
وهنا انفسنا
بقرار فخامه رئيس جمهوريه الوجهه اللقاء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هكذا تحتفل كوريا الشماليه الشيوعيه بذكرى
مولد زعيمها الراحل كيم جونغ ايل رسميا
وشعبيا
فنشر ال الحاد لا يعني ابدا عدم عباده
الحكام يعلق احدهم
في السودان اصبحت لغه الجسد عند الرئيس
عمر البشير تطغى على لغه اللسان ينقص ثم
يخطب ثم يرقص ثم يغادر وهو قدم مشاركه
مدتها ثمانيه عشر دقيقه
[موسيقى]
منحت الحكومه اللبنانيه نفسها الثقه داخل
البرلمان فالحكومه حكومه الكل لكن الكل
انتقدها استباقيا وتبادل بعضهم التهديدات
والشتائم قناه الجديد سالت سائقه تاكسي عن
قصه الشتائم والمسبات
اكثر
الواحد بلبنان ان ما صار له وزير ولا رئيس
لماذا يعيد اللبنانيون انتخاب الطبقه
السياسيه نفسها ثم يعترضون عليها اما ان
تطلعوا عن انتخابهم واما ان ترضوا بالنصيب
اليوم
[موسيقى]
لكن موفد الملك سلمان لبيروت نزار العلوم
كثر الله من امثاله زمان اللبنانيين يجب
ان يقودوا الشرق الاوسط كلها اللبناني نجح
من مكان اللبناني في كل العالم من اجل هذا
النجاح الذي انعكس على الداخل على البلد
الالام النجاح بايديكم وانتم اللي لازم
تقود ال ال ال الشرق الاوسط كله اخيرا
نائب الاردني ينتقد ترك حريه الشتم في
الفايسبوك ثم ينهي مداخلته بشتيمه ا مائيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ختاما يروي من كتاب هروبي الى الحريه علي
عزت بيجوفيتش انه في الوقت الذي اكدت فيه
مدينه نقل الايطاليه من الضحك لعروض
الممثل الكوميدي ك اهلين يا جاء رجل الى
عياده طبيب مشهور في تلك المدينه بسؤال عن
دواء للسوداويه المفرطه التشاؤم الفظيع
والاكتئاب الشديد لقد سلبته صحته وسعادته
ان صحه الطبيب بدوام البحث عن المرح
والتسليه وارشده لحضور عرض الفنان
الكوميدي كابليا نظر المريض في عيني
الطبيب وقال
محسوبه كابليا الى اللقاء بدون عنوان ارخص
من انبات الشعر للرجال في مستشفى بلده
[موسيقى]